I mean I guess there's a lot in Paris
right it was it was incredible one thing
I did which was really nice was went
down to the really really old Paris and
that was like a night or two before
coming back and it was the weather was
kind of nice and just walk around really
old Paris what's like all these hipsters
they have kind of set up shop there and
that was one of the best things I wish I
had found that a little earlier in the
trip she was just walking around looking
at all these amazing art shops and it
was it was incredible
you have [ __ ] incredible you have a
new appreciation for art no I don't care
as much about art that's why didn't
spend a lot of time in the Louvre I
didn't give a [ __ ] let me see that
famous painting I see the [ __ ]
biggest one you got yes show me the
[ __ ] show me that the grand slam what
I look at these little dick statues on
my way out
stop having statue dicks hanging above
the scrotum I was so annoyed they all
have baby dicks why they got little
dicks what are you gonna do that [ __ ] do
you know I did bring my shouldn't
parents I should have done this
I brought the chip wig no and I didn't
do anything with it because I was a no I
was like what am i a hold of myself I
guess I could have but I just felt
stupid leaving the hotel without like
where am I gonna do it I just I didn't
you could have I brought the chip wig
and I just didn't do anyway
you could have just shot footage of chip
in Paris and then made a parody song
called chip as in Paris I should have I
just didn't do that right right would
you produce that trial in a set ship is
in Paris I I didn't I didn't again when
your it felt silly just to stand there
holding up a camera doing [ __ ] by my I
think I'm more asking someone what are
you doing this is what I do now yeah I
don't mind doing it in front of people
who know but in front of people who
don't it's humiliating I also like that
you didn't do work stuff that you just
as Jim Norton as a man yeah I just
enjoyed the Eiffel Tower that would be
more dude I thought of being shipped the
hot like the amount of time I could have
enjoyed him just being around again I
thought it soared
what's that was it hard yeah he's taught
I talk like that to myself
but you start thinking like what like
Clark Kent goes through when he can't be
Superman right Superman
only in America you can't
you can go to Paris Clark and you can
see that all the size but you cannot be
Superman he's got to keep the costume
under his clothes yes I mean what it
needs my help I'm walking by phone booth
after fumbles I can't change I see it on
the street Lois Lane is getting her the
security is so much it'd be hard to
sneak in the cameras but I just thought
of the amount of questions during the
[ __ ] UH the tour of Versailles amount
of questions he could have asked the
annoyance to other people would you know
do you think anybody like all those
people lined up trying to look at the
Mona Lisa everybody standing on top of
each other
do you think that they would have been
happy if chip was trying going up to as
many people as possible and asking them
what they saw how [ __ ] big the
painting on the other hand was why it's
so small how come it's so small yeah I
painted a picture like that I thought of
it the whole time I was there just how
much fun it would have been but it's not
fun just a dude chip just you know with
myself our tour guide who would have
thought I was [ __ ] somebody there
like just knowing that at least somebody
gets it somebody who's into chip right
you know I mean just again doing with
people who don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
about chip it would've been just stupid
and humiliating so that means you were
over there for Christmas too
yeah how did you do anything for
Christmas you know Christmas dinner just
dinner
you know what i mean you [ __ ] call
home talk to the rents did you talk to
the rents on xmas you call home hey
rents it's my ex missed call yeah I
didn't mind them it was it was it was
fun man I was the whole time I realize
I'm like this is the [ __ ] you should
have been doing before right but you
didn't well you're at a point in life
where you can actually appreciate it now
you've accomplished some things you've
made some money you can do this stuff
yeah you don't feel like I didn't feel
like I was like because I don't I don't
do stuff like that right it was again it
was expensive it's an expensive city but
I'm like [ __ ] it man like I don't waste
money on stuff like this but this is
also one of the first times in your life
that you aren't sitting there like
probably I wouldn't imagine you're
sitting there going like oh I got it I
got to do this I got it I should be
doing this I should be doing that like
when you were even a few years younger
you'd be worried about not doing
enough for your career or whatever while
I was obsessed with that but I the
reason I wasn't obsessed with it is
because we looked around for New Year's
Eve gigs and there was some available
but there was nothing that would have
paid more than the tours paying like it
was just there was a regular gig sure
and I'm like I've been working every
[ __ ] weekend and I'm starting work
again the 19th I'm like just go away you
[ __ ] jerk-off let me go be a chip in
Paris yeah I didn't do it I just
couldn't again it you feel silly just
holding I can't do it so we pre-recorded
the Christmas in New Year special and
people enjoyed those yeah it was amazing
amazing and I came home I loved it and I
came home and I hadn't yeah and that
many come home fly home I'm dozing off
on the plane amazing the fight American
Airlines flight incredible first
business business business first is
[ __ ] you know how much okay so if a
business class because I don't know you
know I'm steerage Sammy
but if if business like that I was
[ __ ] I was the coach kid for the
first I know for the first 15 if
business class is seven first of all
what's the difference between business
and coach um it's a big difference in
business in coach it's a bigger seat
it's a lie flat seat the food is a lot
better probably on a flight like that to
on a cross continental flight it's it's
a difference business isn't first the
seats are a little bit bigger there's
not as much difference in business in
first I mean they get international
first I don't think I've ever done that
those are like that's just astronomic I
wouldn't so how much does if a business
class costs $7,000 for a flight I've
never priced them I'm gonna guess I'm
gonna guess they can be 12 or 15 grand
oh it's it's astronomical but again to
do something like that you can if you
can get them cheaper or you can go with
upgrade with miles there's ways to buy
things and upgrade with miles and that's
at a peak time of the year yeah like I
would never I've never I couldn't spend
thousands of dollars but so so you take
your nice look you sorry it's how you
make less money yeah like when I did
Australia I did London I didn't make
that much money doing those gigs at all
because a part of your your your airline
buy out is a bigger buy out so the gig
money pays a lot less right so usually I
kind of made nothing doing London and
doing Australia but I just wanted to see
those places yeah and I mean and they're
getting paid to go somewhere there is
merit to like you know the time
internationally yeah I mean that that
was the main reason for doing those so
there was not a lot of money to be made
I didn't make a lot of money when I did
London I just want to finally go over
there and do the gigs and you kind of
break even or you make a you know a
little bit after but it's honestly
nothing like you would have made if you
just stay at home right but it's who
cares you stay home you know you don't
get see big then I didn't see big bed
anyway what [ __ ] big bed
it's a big clock it is a big good if you
like that painting in the Louvre wait
till you see Big Ben it's [ __ ] you
they do you look at the other side is a
much bigger clock like I came home after
this walk I came home and there was this
amazing trip and I mean again the day
you come back here just kind of situated
I didn't have any sets I'm like I'll
start doing my sets again and during the
midweek which I want to just kind of
relax and I wasn't feeling great because
of the flight so I go to bed and it's
like maybe it's 2 o'clock in the morning
cuz again you're on [ __ ] finish was
to Monday night and it's like it so I'm
laying in bed I'm just about to doze off
and I hear like I thought one of my
[ __ ] windows blew in it was a bizarre
metal creaking now you know nobody's
breaking in because you got floodlight
cams on your patio I'm like what the
[ __ ] yeah is that it was it was a giant
boom and I walked down my hallway and I
hey like I hear a rattling and I'm like
the building's collapsing something
something bad is happening and let me
see here what was happening um let me
see if there's a way to tell you without
actually saying it yeah yeah there is
here let's see I should have to the
sound of some type of a burst and you
can see
this is all flooded what there's water
all over your floors that puddle sound
is so satisfying it was a burst pipe a
burst pipe in their bathroom no it was
between the wall and the outside uh-huh
he wasn't in the bathroom it was in it
was an outside cuz the it froze the pipe
froze and burst and I'm trying to
describe the sound without sounding
stupid it sounded like like a big King
Kong monster taking the building and
squeeze it like a potato perfect King
Kong oh this monster I keep squeezing
all our potatoes when you when you think
of things that are being squeezed you
got to squeeze it a little to make sure
it's right but behind the wall behind
the wall connecting to the outside you
you can hear when I'm walking around you
can hear it vaguely you can hear the
water let me see if you can hear it wait
I'm talking this is for insurance
reasons and of course wait wait can you
hear like sure that sound the bass
doesn't gonna let her fall somebody
squeezing a potato yes that that Shh in
the background that's water still going
down the wall on the inside I was
walking around I didn't hear anything
and I found water and I'm like I'm near
the floor I thought a window blew in or
something and I now understand why
animals right panic because I was just
running around on my floor I'm going oh
no water
oh no no no like you don't know what to
do my underwear I haven't slept on
barefoot it's ice water you're hilarious
as it is cuz you're jet-lagged
I'm vomited tonight let's [ __ ]
vomiting we're sick you're in a
different country you don't know how to
fix [ __ ] in your house anyway so like
you're sitting there there's water on
your floor and you're just kind of run
pacing around the apartment and I'm like
saying oh no it's New Year's night so I
called down to the front desk and we do
how much water a decent amount I can
inch
oh yeah absolutely the only good thing
was it's a water bomb was that I heard
was that I was home and I heard it
that's the only saving grace is that
like I happen to be there because I
called downstairs I'm talking to the
front desk guy and I I you got him a
desert me there's no maintenance guys at
night and I call the super and he said
okay because he didn't know what to do
he was kind of new but but there was uh
he's like I can't get ahold of them and
I'm like do my [ __ ] apartment
well in the end it was too but you
literally when your apartment is
flooding did you have any panic in your
voice you don't you because you can't
stop water right water is coming and I
can't stop it
holy [ __ ] water scary it's not the
inside of the house
it's usually on the outside now it's on
the inside you just think of everything
you've worked for being ruined and like
spoil like my photo you have hardwood
floors I have hardwood floor as your are
your boxes of mementos waterproofed um
you know I got a couple of them are and
it was in my bedroom and I was laying
down towels which literally it would
have been just as effective if I took
contact lenses and it was [ __ ]
pouring in so my super is great because
I have a cell and I called him and he
finally text me like five minutes let's
hold he was happy about ten minutes an
exam or long ten minutes dude it was a
long picture having your dick caught in
a door that's been so he comes happen to
me last year
the flooding yeah I thought the dick
thing yeah a pipe burst in our bathroom
overnight stop slamming the door dude
you feel like don't you you don't know
what to do your [ __ ] is being flooded so
the super comes up and apparently
there's a shutoff valve for that that
particular line because it goes to an
outside hose but no one knew where it
was it's different in the different
apartment so he ran downstairs meanwhile
they had called the before he get the
super the guy called the fire department
he just didn't know what to do at the
front desk so before the super comes up
I'm standing there in the doorbell rings
seven firemen are there with axes I
haven't [ __ ] two cops and they walk
in and luckily I had to unplug all my
[ __ ] like nothing thank God I am I
unplugged Italy as the water was coming
in as you're speaking in my mind's eye
you're still in your underpants
was I mind what no I had a pair of no I
threw jeans on and I rolled up the legs
I oh I have a oh no you didn't like oxen
yes and I was saying I was referring to
my my friend is that one of the same
things hold on this is your your your
your jeans rolled up and a piece of
straw weight hanging out of your mouth
see if you can see this again it's all
for insurance see if you can see my feet
watch you rolled your you rolled your
jeans up into capris yeah what a loser
how bad is that high waters big yeah big
manly fire men come in and cops and
you've got your high water jeans rolled
up you don't know where the water's
coming from it first it's coming from
under there's no hole in the wall sure
so you don't know if it's an outside
thing or if it's an inside thing and
then I the fireman came in and they're
standing with axes there's two cops
behind them right and literally then the
super came up when they were there and
they're like okay we think it's coming
from behind the wall you could hear then
you realize what that noise was that was
the water flowing and the firemen
literally as I'm standing there they're
like all right let's go I'm like I
thought they're gonna help me clean up
and move the bed and get the water out
of there they literally were looking at
me like they walked in and I had on
heels and I was going oh boys my
Tootsie's are cold they couldn't have
hated me more once but I didn't I didn't
know what to die did call in the guy
downstairs just didn't know what to do
so thank God were taken care of this was
a [ __ ] do they would have acted and
and then just showed us where it was in
the wall but the super was great he ran
downstairs to the basement he shut down
the whole line of the building on that
side and then that kind of stopped the
bleeding and then he brought up these
vacuum things but people downstairs got
[ __ ] up none you can do I mean it's
just it was a it was so cold it's
record-breaking cold that the pipes once
in a while burst and they said that the
the buildings have had these things like
I call the insurance field the next
and like it's the most common thing
we're getting I mean everyone's
buildings having [ __ ] pipes explode
I'd be in such [ __ ]
if I get burst pipes in my house but you
realize like you got a plan for that you
should get one of those VAX that sucks
up the water
and find out where your shut-off valves
are yeah I know my shutoff valves are
and we got the sub pump but if it's it
by the way if it's an inside valve like
not in that line I there's no shutoff
valve for it it's just the main one in
the basement so it's a whole thing
but you realize how helpless you are
like thank God it wasn't fire and thank
God it was 24 hours before how helpless
you're in tow deep water just what no
but like you can't stop it from coming
mm-hmm so it [ __ ] up my bedroom is
totally like I have to have all the wood
don't read on just just a mold but
insurance will take care of yeah yeah I
mean yeah it's one of those things that
you have homeowners insurance for and
then it seeps under the walls into the
next room and from my office to my rugs
were ruined but again it didn't go to
the living room it didn't [ __ ] up like
it sucked but I was really lucky I was
home at the end of like by the end of
the night I me had gotten a lot of the
water up and the super was great so it's
like you yeah at this thinks but [ __ ] it
I was here does your apartment smell
musky no no no it doesn't I don't know
why it doesn't but who know maybe it was
just cold water coming down that pipe
but but again I have people coming today
to look at it and start the floors and
it's gonna be a long process now they
have to [ __ ] rip them up do all this
mold stuff and then do the next room
it's gonna be a nightmare for the next
[ __ ] couple of months of who and you
have wood floors put down they got a
[ __ ] bring in the wood and let it sit
in your apartment for a while to get
used to the way the air is so they don't
put it down and it doesn't contract and
expand it's a whole [ __ ] thing these
construction workers got to do yeah so
this next like month or two is gonna
suck yeah but you realize you you
realize hey man I'm home and joke
whatever what if it happens again and
you're not that's true dude I couldn't
you don't understand I have not stopped
thinking about that how great would it
have been how great would it have been
if this happened on December 26 you
really do think constantly no it
wouldn't because the people downstairs
like because of where the pipe was it
was just happy to be in the middle of
the wall and a thank God it didn't come
to my ceiling yeah honey it sounds like
someone's squeezing a potato
the neighbor upstairs squeezing potatoes
again but dude I'm laying in bed and
every noise I hear I'm like flying
because they had the guy company and he
put in like a uh a noose nuage shutoff
valve and they're putting in a new vent
right we're out like right in my room
like as opposed to in another room I can
just get if God forbid because that
because you realize that that posted
that pole of the outside is exposed the
[ __ ] is that scary you think about it
right I every time we leave we went up
to Montreal for four days and it's the
only thing on my mind while we're
driving there is what because oh all I
did was just one random night a little
piece of the pipe on the toilet burst at
like 11 o'clock I was sleeping Lisa was
out she came home and there was just
water coming out wait everywhere is
there a shutoff on your toilet though
where you got righty-tighty lefty-loosey
yeah something like that and she figured
it out because like and it stopped the
water and it's not the water but we
still had an inch of water in almost our
entire apartment what did you lose
because you realize how much [ __ ] you
leave you don't realize how much of your
shits on the floor until water comes in
the room we lost rugs we lost a few
things nothing like nothing major but
the fact that all of our electric does
know the dogs they're good thank God
lost his bed but we bought him a new one
because we love them but you realize
that that [ __ ] could happen any time
whether you're there or not and and and
if you're not there you could be [ __ ]
and what if it's in another room like if
it had happened again what if it's like
one of the ones because all your [ __ ]
water pipes are in your ceiling so like
what if it happened in the hallway oh my
god the first thing I did was when I ran
in I heard it rattling in the wall I'm
okay there's a problem before I even
knew there was water I thought something
was going to burst I went and got my
sign Black Sabbath for that we just
stand on the sofa did I put it on the
sofa before I didn't realize officers is
that you know see yourself in your knees
standing up on the couch holding his
Black Sabbath folks don't know me I'll
be in the living room I'll be the boy
holding the signed picture of four
alcoholics
so I don't understand it's so hard to
get them all together I [ __ ] I really
did I took my sign Sabbath
off the wall and ran I thought the wall
was gonna blow in I didn't know what it
was because the pipes are all connected
so in there rattling I'm like the walls
gonna cave in but you realize that if
that happens anywhere and just rains
down on your [ __ ] and in a weird way you
have this you have a weird thing about
your possessions when this happen like
alright this sucks but I'm like I did
lose a few sign things that were in a
box not I get nothing major just a few
little things all right but you realize
like okay it is what it is there's like
almost nothing you can do about it you
don't want to lose your computer stop
for all your the things I've written
over the years but I'm like besides my
photos and the things I've written like
that's mostly what I care about on my
computer I'm now completely terrified of
of the basement flooding dude you should
get you if you got a sump pump or
whatever yeah we do and there's got to
be an automatic shutoff you can put on
the fly have that for my washer dryers I
think this automatic shutoff where if
water leaks you [ __ ] a switch comes
and turns the water off I wonder if
there's ways to get that in every room
where if water floods in because it is
scary if I wasn't home eventually they
would have realized they were just
broken into my apartment and shut it off
right they would have you shut the water
down everything would have been so wet
though it would have been literally
might have been a week of your apartment
sitting in water probably managers
coming home to that yeah so as opposed
to being in like why me why me I'm like
[ __ ] lucky I was here it just
couldn't have happened at a better time
I was here and I'm lucky I was here
lucky you're on it so then you what time
they finally get finished up there well
I was I mean til the next morning
because the guy had to go downstairs and
take care of the other sure people and
so I was just upstairs he brought up
this vacuum and I was just vacuuming but
I couldn't move the rugs myself because
my beds on them or myself so I had to
wait for him to come back up and then we
rolled up the rugs threw them outside on
the terrace can you help me with the
rugs too can you help me sir help me I
can't do the rugs by myself I don't know
how to do them but I moved everything
and then the floor was kind of dry by
the end of the night like literally or
so then you were up all day yesterday I
I dozed off and I got knocks at the door
because in the maintenance people had
come in and they wanted to do some
expecting and I'm a bond and they had to
have someone come in and put it a new
vow so I was up all day until last night
so last night I'm I'm in bed by 8:30 and
I didn't fall asleep till 11:00 because
you keep thinking you're hearing
creaking pipes then you just realize
it's just the neighbors squeezing
potatoes
Toland is thank god giant king kong
monster just squeezing their potatoes
it's not an issue but it's nice to know
that that doesn't go away no anyone what
the fear of yeah because you realize
like I get I get trauma now you know
like on a small scale I get it but don't
you it never leaves it never leaves it
does no stolen valor Travis don't don't
equate this with PTSD yeah but you
understand how little things like you
can't shake it like the idea of running
around in the water helpless like I
really was just go no water well you're
you're lucky that you have super I mean
I'm having you all day Cooper right you
don't oh yeah I mean we're in a we're in
a garden apartment facility which is
like you know just a shitload of to
story like townhomes yeah but yeah we
have a maintenance yeah I'm supposed to
be a man who does his own thing yeah
[ __ ] that I'm never owning a house I
don't want that like you have so much it
sucks if your house happens you're on
your own dude I called plumber I called
three [ __ ] plumbers one of them is
like maybe in three hours they can text
you on the way and the other ones like I
got nothing till tomorrow Paul that's
how good it was happening all over the
city could was so [ __ ] cold that
every night they were on call so even a
24 hour plumber is hard to find
yeah I just hate it being squeezed yeah
that's potato squeezing season what are
we gonna do yeah yeah I'm like water
sensors guys are saying and I know where
all my valves are so I know how to shut
the water off it yeah how so you you
have to in the house that's already
different in the building there sure of
course
the only valve I could have shut off was
this one but again nobody knows where it
is and you don't think it hey is there
different valves one to an outside water
sword but if it happens on the inside
there's no valve you the guy has to go
downstairs to the basement and just shut
it off yeah so again thank God you live
in a building where there's a guy who
knows what he's doing
yeah I mean nobody's there but we called
the 24-hour line and some guy that's on
call came and you know didn't really
help how long did it take him to get
there um 3045 minutes yeah and if you
don't know how to shut the water off
that's a long time he had the water shut
off already but you know we still had to
clean up the entire do they have to redo
your floors no dude
well sure they would she'd have that
redone yeah I mean we're not an a in a
situation like yours where we can just
up and leave
oh but he won't insurance insurance
might cover that that's what I'm saying
like I like insurance recovery I'm
staying in a hotel while they fix the
floors yeah I don't have to pay for any
of it it's all homeowners insurance or
whatever we rented may you had all that
what that wouldn't fall under renters
insurance because that would be their
issue what I mean like that would be the
the landlord's issue it's theirs yeah
but I think that insurance would you you
should investigate that for health did
you get your you don't want you your
wife and your kid breathing in mold you
should really do that dude should be
fine six months ago yeah these kids and
their immune systems unbelievable they
should be fine absolutely you should
have a guy come in and check that all
right you should absolutely have a
[ __ ] mole you should talk to your
landlord you have to pay for any of it
it was a fun [ __ ] up pipe that I'm not
worried about paying for any of it yeah
it's not our bro he's got the cash he's
not worried about [ __ ] you should have
somebody come in I know I should you
know that's really dangerous yeah I know
I know well what a way to end your your
spectacular European vacation vacate a
beige 18 is the year of a cage a rules
yeah I think so too yeah it was a fun
guys a fireman yeah well the fireman is
smiling at least yeah I think it's
important I didn't I stayed I stayed
home all vacation which was good I did
it was good to do Christmas with a kid
because yeah he realized like oh this is
what Christmas is fun did he did he
understand anything different was
happening or no yes
well like I stayed up oh well you know
cuz I mean you don't really you could do
Christmas it would need we need these 10
months old you could do Christmas or not
do Christmas it doesn't matter because
you do it just for the figures you do
make sure isn't a thing but yeah yeah we
got him a bunch of stuff some of the
stuff has been sitting in our garage for
a while or like it was given to us by
other people or whatever but you just
put new toys in
room and like I got him a giant ball
that's like twice the size of him just
so you know it's like you know again see
it yeah
and so like he walked in on Christmas
morning and recognized in his toy room
with the free stuff he has new toys and
she freaked out you know he freaks out
at Sesame Street so we got him like a
little Elmo he likes it he likes that he
freaked out about that but it's like you
know and we have a three-year-old niece
so watching the three-year-old and our
little dude like it made it it made you
realize how awkward it is to do
Christmas when it's all just adults
right like in that in that period of
time where you're all grown up but
nobody has kids yet like you're in your
late 20s or sometimes early 30s and like
you're still just kind of going you know
opening presents at your mom's house or
Travis a lot of people still do it at
their moms yes what is it what is that
word yeah no ma it's like it's it's the
female version of death he pictured are
you just sitting in the shoulder the
road in the parkway like it really it
really drives it home how you know
Christmas is a thing for further for
children for children that's what that's
what it's for it's which it's way better
though and it's fun watching them freak
out over new [ __ ] and opening their
stuff and and do all that yeah it was a
good time and then other than that I
mean I did some shows like I did I did
Legion of skanks oh how was that that
was fun yeah we talking about Mary Jean
oh my god yes I think Lewis and herd
fought they did yeah people got up on
Twitter like what are you going over or
it was like her and Lewis had a fight a
physical almost a physical and then she
called in and of course we're gonna talk
like what do you guys want
but I also like I looked at Lewis Isaac
Lewis I was like you are not going to
sit there and convince me that you Lewis
J Gomez are a guy who thinks that
because there was conflict this person
should not be on the radio you are the
most conflict seeking radio person of
all time I know Louis stood up like he
was ready for a fit again Lewis not
gonna let anybody hit him I don't bite
on blame Lewis for not wanting to be hit
then don't get weird without people get
with us if somebody [ __ ] calls up we
want to talk him what happened of course
I thought what happened but it was fine
you know let me know I was like doing
that show and
did Tom Shalu show one day because he
was on during that week oh he was miss a
new year so I did that show I did a
bunch of shows from for YouTube you know
live shows I heard you I saw your
countdown did the new year new year's
lonely Eve by myself that's great was
fun yeah did you have callers no I mean
I don't have phone setup so I the only
person so I put on my tux as you can see
in the photo I put on my tux
and I got I went to Party City earlier
in the day and I got like confetti
poppers and New Year's hats and
noisemakers and like signs to put up in
everything and then just went down like
1115 and did my own new year's countdown
that's great just by myself talking I
just picked up the mic a couple of times
but I was talking like the people in the
YouTube chat and just doing it but one
of the funnier moments was I knew Kevin
was gonna marry Maria on New Year's he
we had talked about it earlier but it
was like a surprise and so I told him I
was like well I'm doing this thing and
he was like wow I could try to get you
into Times Square but there's only like
room for 4 people on the platform that
we have there's no space there's like
don't you know I don't even I don't need
to be in time yeah for years anyway if
you I said if you wanted me there as
like a friend I would be there but if
it's like you trying to do something
cool for me don't worry about it I'll
see you guys then and so that's what I
did but he called me when I was doing
the show so it's like 11:30 and I'm
sitting there with the TV on ready to
talk about this marriage that's gonna
happen on the YouTube show and my cell
phone rings and I put him on speaker and
he's like while I'm doing the YouTube
show he's like hey Sam
just getting miked up getting ready to
go Bob he just called the check in on
the show and just to say hello eyes gave
me why now he's on live TV 5 minutes
before he's marrying Maria Menounos in
Times Square on live television
Kevin is a bit of a psycho like once in
a while I'll wake up and he's he is an
idea guy no haven't Undergaro is a
[ __ ] that you know that like he
really thinks the things and tries to
make things work and he's a really hard
worker so once in a while I'll wake up
to a bunch of texts with with ideas yeah
and they're all good and I'm like you
know I didn't see that until the next
morning and like yeah he's a guy who's
always thinking always always like way
doesn't sleep
he's in total insomnia he is a [ __ ]
crazy person he's up all night yeah he's
up all night and like I can always tell
when he's been up all night cuz he just
stays up all night listening to shows
like he puts his ear buds in and he goes
to sleep like that
just because he's all over the place and
he doesn't he doesn't sleep much so
Murray will go to bed and he'll just
price it in the next room no he'll still
well he developed a couple of things
he'll so she doesn't like when he comes
in in the middle of the night he's
waking up right so he goes to bed when
she goes to bed but he'll either have
his laptop or just on his phone and just
have his ear buds in and listening
because she also didn't like the laptop
being sure cuz it kept her up yes so he
I don't know if he still uses it but he
created this invention called the man
curtain where it's a retractable because
he's also like he used to work in is a
carny so he knows how to build [ __ ] you
know he's the one who built with the
studio with me and in the and my house
right and he built this contraption
that's a retractable curtain where at
nighttime he could put up a curtain
between he and Maria so that he could be
on his laptop and she can go to sleep
flying business class it's like there's
this like it's like PVC pipe that comes
up from the end of the bed and then he
stretches the curtain across and then he
could do his stuff he could do his work
he can type and then he puts the curtain
down but I think I do think that Maria
might have put the kibosh on that too
you I wonder because I understand the
insomnia and how frustrating it is
you're laying there and you can't sleep
it might sound like something basic but
are you drinking coffee too late and is
your phone they say you're having your
phone right by your head when you sleep
is bad mm-hmm keep it across the room so
I started like for the last two weeks
keeping it across the room and I noticed
in most cases I've slept a little bit
better because it's just not right by
your head right it's not an option yeah
and don't be on the laptop right before
it's it's hard to do but I won't if he's
on his laptop too late oh yeah I mean
he's in bed doing all that stuff and
thinking and so I chose he sleep during
the day when she gets up he'll just stay
in bed know when oh are you kidding me
no way when she gets up he gets up like
it's time to go to work like he produces
everything she does but he's part of
everything so no absolutely not you know
at one point he was like you know a
couple years ago he had to I had to kind
of change his life and stuff because he
started
they diagnosed him with adrenal fatigue
just because he had been going and going
and going and going
adrenal fatigue I wonder what is that
there's some of the just constant
exhaustion I thought I had that at one
point so I went to again what did he
take for Gina I don't know he had a
whole whole thing it was like over the
course of years but he'd be a good
person to talk to me yeah that's
interesting but yeah I mean he uh no he
goes [ __ ] he goes nuts non-stop work
yeah non-stop work but you guys are just
like that they need like a couple hours
of it's a bit dizzy function well on
three hours key functions great I mean
as far I mean III don't well he
functions great when I work with him so
and you know he doesn't sleep well so I
think he functions great on nothing
worse than sitting there in bed in the
person you with it's sleep like a log
you know what the [ __ ] it how do they do
that
oh I saw worse yeah I must be nice I
don't know I don't get frustrated about
it anymore you get frustrated when I was
a kid because I couldn't sleep so I had
to I had to get past all that cuz I get
like anxiety about not stopping and then
you're going to bed it's a whole thing
right and so now I don't I don't might
sleep like it's on my it's like number
100 on my list of concerns like I don't
even look at it as a thing anymore you
know you'll do when you need to do it
right just because otherwise I freaked
out yeah and if you're tired you're
tired exactly at some point your body
will just shut down and you'll have to
sleep or you'll die or something
yeah it is what it is but what are you
gonna do constantly knowing that the bed
is a place that you're going to struggle
right sleep wise and sexually yeah
that's why I don't do any any any
sleeping tricks anymore if I'm tired
I'll fall asleep if I'm not tired I'm
gonna watch TV I'm gonna look at my
phone I don't I don't do any of it yeah
when you're looking at the phone though
otherwise otherwise it stresses me out
and and instead of you know all these
tricks of falling asleep I just get
stressed out of the fact that I can't
sleep so I didn't do any of that stuff
oh good downstairs and go live on
YouTube or something I mean that's kind
of cool be able to do that ever it was
and that's what I was really like
experimenting with over the vacation
just because I can go on my said Queen I
could just go on whenever I want so
whenever stuff was going on or I just
had an opinion about something you just
go on and and and put the chat on live
and people signed on and you tweet and
say this is what I'm doing yeah yeah you
tweet like right I tweet right before
I'm going on hey I'm gonna go on YouTube
and then I just sign on to the YouTube
channel and do you discuss what they're
to like well you'll talk with the people
when they're I'll have a my topics like
there's or like I'm doing the show like
it's not like it's not cuz it's you know
if you're gonna build that whole studio
and everything and you have to have a
show you're it's like a show like it's
not just me on my phone like talking to
the comment or yeah like I'm actually no
I'm doing a show there's a purpose
to the show yeah you actually you're
saying where you want to discuss
something right and then like you know
every now and then I'll glance over at
the screen and look at the comments
address go back to the topic at hand but
I tried to move the comments towards the
topic the reason for the show it's not
just hey you can look at my phone and
read comments like that's not a show I
enjoy I enjoy you know a lot of times
I've gone on Facebook live in stuff I've
talked to people who are commenting in
it's a way like they're asking questions
I don't mind answering questions right
that's that's it I like doing that I
like that too that's a different thing
as well but I think that's having a show
or having an idea of what you want to do
is smart yeah I just write out like you
know especially when we're not on the
air and there's stuff going on I'm oh
yeah yeah I want to talk about this that
and this and I just go down and and and
then kind of just see what happens just
like when we do the show here yeah it's
a guy let's see it's kind of planned we
have news stories a bunch of stuffs and
videos we don't talk about our vacations
and what we did yeah yeah I thought
about the whole time I was there like
I'll talk about this week yeah this
happened that happened that part of
these days you're doing stuff to do you
know you have to come and talk about on
the air right so I don't just say I mean
I could have come back sooner but I'm
like like for what just to go to the
like I mean I love the seller and I love
these are the places where I come back
and just do a few sets that I could do
any time right no I stay in Paris you
fruit yeah yeah
a lovely city lovely people I was
completely wrong about Europe completely
it's amazing I was I think everybody
kind of knew you were gonna be wrong
though nobody was like yeah Jim's right
no I know but I mean I think were you
Travis no like there's you didn't think
there's any merit to his argument right
now there's a busy LAN there how gonna
be bad that's true
I saw the Disney Store and Charles de
Gaulle Airport I would have gone there
I did it you go to Disneyland no we're
going it's in Paris oh my go
no I wrote Disney it's that called euro
doesn't anymore no Paris excuse me oh I
didn't go to any dirty places either why
there's a weird sex district that I
walked through just to looks like a fine
Oh ten blocks of like sexy but I didn't
mean like when Lina stores nothing he
just even knows down there she's lying
around it was like kind of like Times
Square was but nowhere near is dirty
that's pretty incredible
everybody was just kind of like normal
looking around and you didn't feel dirty
yeah I walked by a Moulin Rouge
voulez-vous coucher avec moi oh I
[ __ ] hate it
what about the what about the whatever
who sings that what about the redo the I
hate it with Christina Aguilera
I [ __ ] and the pink is in it I'd
rather listen to the sound of water
crashing into my Sabbath photo [ __ ]
song what do you know okay yeah yeah and
and and the queen bee little Kim is in
it and and Maya Maya is still relevant
right - still got hits right Troy you
ever play Maya
- she fell off man that's too bad yeah
but this was big Moulin Rouge was a oh
yeah and Missy Elliott is here to
introduce us remember and she goes
Christina were you singing this when you
were passing by the Moulin Rouge
so I hate this song there's Maya she
still got it
she's hot as she was she was done yeah
what year is a song 99 maybe it's 2000
to 2002 okay
[Music]
get you get you yeah it's sexy I hate
get you a TI y zero at boule vous
coucher I read wah wah means yes kill
yourself Oh gitchy gitchy yeah yeah
that's
I hate this one you do what is it's baby
talk [ __ ] you chica - yeah yeah yeah
whatever it is oh they're sinking little
Kim Kristina all the ladies of the
moment coming together I [ __ ] hate it
Pinkus don't make it songs now huh yes
she's still around there's a tour de
force as this was a tour de force that's
the correct terminology for it how many
people you think sing hum this to
themselves cuz they're walking by the
Moulin Rouge going Oh cutie cutie yeah
yeah I don't know normal I can't I
forgot about this song did you said you
didn't think about that when you walk by
the moulin oh yeah there's a movie about
that yeah get you get you yeah yeah you
thought that didn't think that no you
didn't thank God it would have ruined my
trip oh I knew I walked by the Moulin
Rouge and it was something about it that
I hated I feel an overwhelming negative
presence since I walked past this
building I just didn't want to go into
it I know it's a very famous place about
what a little Kim gets a little street
she's talking about spending her man's
money
I like Lil Kim see okay I enjoy like her
voice she's great she's still doing the
thing right Troy you know it's funny is
she has this song out now with uh what's
her name Remy Ma and I'm like wow early
two-thousands rappers that are yeah cuz
we monitored last year Remy Ma bodying
Nicki Minaj but who would have thought
both of them would fall by the wayside
because cardi B is that hot [ __ ] right
Hey look his white now that's right Lil
Kim is but she's a her and Sammy Sosa oh
yeah she's got the same Associate thing
going on where she's like completely
white and and has no resemblance to that
person in the Moulin Rouge video
christina was hot the S she was she
probably wants to remove the memories of
this song who does welcome so she became
white like I can't be that person I
cannot do that oh it's great I like the
name of the song that I'm the name of
the who's Lady Marmalade Marvel odd oh
that's the name of the song Lady
Marmalade
it's from the from the hit movie Moulin
Rouge
[ __ ] hate it yeah Baz Luhrmann was
like hey man I need
a song to go into my movie and the girls
were like we got you bears we got you it
was that big song he did that what the
one Baz Luhrmann's uh the talk song do
you remember the song that sure but you
know the song when you hear it did you
get you yeah yeah it's a [ __ ]
terrible sunscreen hmm you know this
song everybody's free to wear sunscreen
that might be it that sounds familiar
oh yeah it's like the other side Troy no
turn your iPod off and just the computer
do you remember I remember it being a
thing but I don't have any look-back
recollection of the actual song calling
away you can't grasp now how much
possibility lay before you and how
fabulous I don't like Baz Luhrmann you
know I don't care about him either way
but I just remember this I didn't care
about the Romeo and Juliet movie Moulin
Rouge sucked
what else did he do he did one on one
that's kind of recently didn't he this
song sucks Jay Gatsby I don't like this
song Great Gatsby was great this is a
song this sucks
I've never heard this before he had to
do a whole this was this was huge yeah
yeah totally even ever heard he had to
do a whole bunch getting garbage no
before he got to Great Gatsby you see
Great Gatsby know who's good you've
heard this Troy yes but then again
Leonardo DiCaprio was in it he's the
[ __ ] man yeah Leo was in Romeo and
Juliet yeah but he wasn't the man then
that's when he was like frilly frilly
boy Titanic Leo true he was still the
man he wasn't the man then no not a
grape no he wasn't the man and it's
[ __ ] come on I know a thing or two
about a thing or two
he was boys like man them no he was
basically leaner he was basically
Jonathan Taylor Thomas then yeah now
catch me if you can that's my that's
when he became the man that's a great
yeah I think you're right I think you
guys are crazy he was great in this
boy's life yeah but he was there mustard
in that jar he was a little boy though
exactly still he's still cool but he
wouldn't know but he was a good actor
he's great Basketball Diaries he was
great he was
I'm not saying he was a bad young actor
but I am saying he wasn't the man do you
think weren't like oh that dudes that
dudes the [ __ ] man now I'm like no I
don't think about him is the man now he
is I think he's a great actor
no he's the dude catchment cam was so
good so [ __ ] good hands one of my
favorite movies Tom Hanks is like
looking at that bottle the labels been
peeled off
he's like Abagnale hey how's your wife
is she good they're the stupid animal
Lecter Jodie Foster relationship super
[ __ ] move ya got no one else to call
oh I fell down the steps yeah that's the
one where he's like hey Francis
I put your watch in my [ __ ] I thought
of that the walk-in I Bob introduced me
to him at the Christmas party you you
are a true piece of [ __ ] you might never
talked about that what I'm here piece of
garbage why because there's just no
reason to bring that up it wasn't casual
I totally forgot about it yeah me too
I'm sorry actually I hadn't forgotten
about I was talking to somebody about
you the other day might be Kevin that is
a wedding thing I was like yeah I go now
he's doing he's doing he's going to the
the DeNiro party he's meeting
Christopher Walken what's wrong with
that if a guy if a guy says you want to
come to my family's Christmas party you
go do you are you not gonna yes I
invited you to Thanksgiving you didn't
come busy Bob would call you sit there
chatting and then Chris Walken comes
over and introduce you what do you I do
not say hello
Robert you went to the Robert DeNiro
family Christmas party
yeah so who didn't I didn't I wasn't
invited I thought you were getting us a
plus for them yeah yeah but anyway Chris
came over and introduced me hey doing
Christopher Walken yeah oh yeah I think
I have the because I don't think we ever
really talked about this
I sent me the most annoying it might be
the most annoying text I've ever gotten
let me see if I can find it here because
it was it was before brave just yeah I
just don't put the location or date no
no no just stuff he makes public no it
was just your gibart I mean we talk so
much I have to scroll up a little bit
not something to brag about let's see
there was one moment where I was had to
[ __ ] at the Christmas party that was
gonna leave you knows Lee was there and
I'm standing there and I'm saying
goodbye to him and Harvey Keitel is
sitting there and some girl gets a
picture with Keitel and she wants one
with De Niro and Keitel so I'm standing
there with him just talking and he grabs
me just to be in the picture
so I [ __ ] photo bomb so for that I
didn't meet to with some girl's photo
with you know what I tell them I'm in it
and I don't have it I don't know who it
is so this was a text I got a couple a
couple weeks ago you were asking me if I
was doing the chip show I was like yeah
I should be able to make it bubble boy
and then you just sent me this text
which I thought was weird because you
normally don't just vent but I was like
oh I on it you got me I honestly was
like oh maybe Jim's having like kind of
a rough day like I'll be here for him as
a friend I had such an annoying day
today I can't talk about it until I get
back from Europe because I wound up good
because it wound up being so annoying
and I go really question mark question
mark question mark
what happened question mark and this is
he I knew immediately he goes I'm in the
middle of talking to Bob and [ __ ]
Chris comes over so Bob introduces me to
Chris and I just sat there staring at
the text and I was like well I know who
Bob is I was like oh it's not Oh
and so my response was an ellipses dot
dot dot Chris poom and I just get a text
back that says walk in oh you know
what's annoying about that exactly
nothing then why did you say you had an
annoying game oh just you talking to one
person somebody else comes in oh I see I
see
but yeah anyway - Buchanan's a [ __ ]
great yeah I mean you probably watch it
differently because you know the guy but
you know it is one of my favorite movies
do anything it's so good it's so [ __ ]
good I love the fact that they're both
still alive you mean really really real
yeah the real Avenel and I think that
sometimes when I fly how difficult how
different
back then to be able to say get on a
flight you're not even a cat but like
the [ __ ] you could get away with in
1968 if you were a flirt and could stick
airplane toy airplane stickers on a
check ya ape through a toilet what's it
yeah well yeah what's the name of the
pilot that sits without flying the plane
Oh deadhead are you my dad head yeah
yeah yeah and because there's no way for
them to check on a computer no he's just
[ __ ] stewardesses how funny how funny
would it have been if when they said are
you my deadhead he started singing touch
of gray it's a Grateful Dead song Rachel
yeah do you like that the Dead has it
that's my new big song I knew where you
were going yeah that's like their hit I
love that everyone hates that song and
it's great it's like what the why yeah
oh my god